I just mentioned one of your movies
stepbrothers and it's interesting that
movie has like seems to have like a long
tail you came out with that movie a
couple years ago with willow Hale well
know what I mean yeah it is it is it has
a a growing fan base it seems people
really love that movie and their intense
about it yeah correct yeah people are
very intense about it
someone yeah and I love the fact that
that but I'm really proud of that movie
I'm so happy that it continues to grow
in in love in the audience but people do
take it really far sometimes a friend
recently sent me a photograph of a young
man who got a couple tattoos on his body
that I thought was one step too far
personally for me right
you mean I don't really believe in
tattoos because I'm too fickle yeah but
this guy well I think we brought a
picture about a picture this is a guy
there's Emma Kane
[Applause]
okay so you got your he got Will Ferrel
yeah on the left cheek yeah and under
him it says boats yeah boats and then
you on the right cheek under which it
says hose I mean the only thing that
comes between me and will these days is
the usual
yeah what'd you have
would you have if you had talked to that
guy or had a chance to interact with him
and he told you how much he loved the
movie and then he told you John I gotta
go out and get this tattoo would you
have tried to talk about it no people
come up to me often actually to say you
know oh my gosh oh my gosh you can tell
they've been waiting for years to show
me like my face on their calf or you
know like and somehow you're just I'm
just a little disappointed in them like
really I mean I'm happy for you but did
you really like and one girl came up to
me one night I was getting in a car late
at night and she ran oh my gosh John see
probably will you we please we write my
your name I sign my arms on my arm and I
was like all right yeah so I sign her
arm she's like I'm going to the tattoo
parlor right now to have your signature
tattoo and I was like please wait 24
hours think about it just a little bit
yes I don't know I just think if your
body is like a temple and like I don't
know like the old you get the less cool
tattoos look as they start to sag and
lose their that but one isn't looking
good now
you know that's I agree looking good nap
on now I gotta give it to that guy for
the commitment commitment yeah he has a
lot of commitment
how does he enjoy the tattoo yeah and
how does he show it to friends like
that's how he shows it to friends I
think he just dropped you throw it says
he showed it to a lot of friends tonight
yeah
you